i change the word think to notice
because
think makes you identify with your
thoughts i think there's an ownership
tone and kind of command to that
uh word i think me
um you know what i noticed notice put
you back
so you're observing observing it working
versus actively thinking about you're
watching something okay because you
don't have to notice gives you that half
a beat to connect to it from church
give me an example um all right i
i i noticed that guy's he's always angry
oh
you know what i think that guy's always
angry he's an [ __ ]
i noticed that guy's always an [ __ ]
that's such a better way to say
something right just hey i noticed
you're an [ __ ] i noticed you're an
[ __ ]
this is not if i think you're an [ __ ]
i think you're an ad
i notice you're an [ __ ] that is such
a better way to insult somebody oh
i'm i'm at 47. i'm throwing that in my
arsenal hey
i noticed you're an [ __ ]
have you ever picked up on this
it just struck me i happen to notice
you're an ass
have you done something with your hair
no i think i think you're an [ __ ] i'm
just
oh god oh man that is
[ __ ] god i can't wait i just i might
randomly
upset somebody today just use it on them
to get it out of my system
i can't wait to say it yeah i had a
whole thing yesterday i have not popped
off on somebody in
you know in quite a while even with
stupidity whatever
yesterday i'm at the drive-through i get
a i get a
large unsweetened iced tea it's all i'm
getting
and i'm at the pay window and they got
the guy
at the you know he must have had a
special order they said pull up to that
space right there yeah but he's right in
front of me
and i can see he's having words with a
young kid that works there
right and the kid's like whatever and he
walks away and i hear that guy in the
in the car he's got a jeep cherokee he
goes uh what's your name
and then the kid doesn't say anything so
i'm about to i get my drink and i'm
about to pull out and this dude backs up
and i mean he pulls
within an inch of me so i can't move
right
and i'm i mean the drive through windows
right here i can't get out of my car to
go
i would literally have to climb into the
passenger seat to go out that door to
come around which i didn't think looked
very masculine
[Laughter]
and the guy's not moving i'm like move
your [ __ ] truck dude i gotta go
and he's like i asked for the manager i
go you can pull over there and talk to
the [ __ ] manager so the manager comes
in
and she's like what's going on i go this
[ __ ] has blocked me in
i can't leave i just want to [ __ ] go
he's like i want the match we'll go
move your [ __ ] truck i'm blowing the
horn and [ __ ] but i can't get out i
can't do anything
and then i'm like get out are you the
manager she goes yeah i'm like get out
there and deal with this dude
so she goes out and makes him leave and
i just pull up and he's got his window
down i go hey and he looks at me i go
i can i don't know what's going on here
but i can tell you're the [ __ ]
problem and i just drove away
but i wish i could have said hey you
know what i don't understand
i wish i had that yesterday i wish i had
that yesterday
that is such a i feel like people have
to process that
[Laughter]
wait he notices
what is it what is it about me that
you've noticed that triggered that
response
i had a guy oh god i had a guy the other
day
it was it was a guy it was a woman and
she was driving
and there was a guy next to him and i
was coming out of the bank so the car is
here
there's no directional on they but and
so this lane is open i had to make a
right turn so
you know it's not a marked street and
there's no light you know uh wilshire
when you come when you hit the wrong
side street on wilshire there's no light
you're like [ __ ] i'm here for a day now
yeah i'm here for an hour and a half
so i'm here so i i go this way they were
making a right but she didn't have a
directional
so i just did this i just inched out i
made the right and she
she went to do it i guess she oh she
knew i was there because it was a blind
spot but i had no indication that that's
where she was going
pull up to the light i'm on this lane
now she's here so she's here and i'm
here and she's through my passenger
window she rolls down the window
she goes really sweet move yeah she's
yelling at me she's like
you know what and she's an older lady
she goes would you do that if your
mother was in the car and i went my
mother knows how to [ __ ] drive
her eyes
and the guy the guy sitting next to her
he went like this he would you could say
he had one
laugh but he was like
tell her again say it i'm a hostage
i actually i actually felt bad because
she thought it was just some civilian
you know she wasn't like you know she
had no idea she had no idea
where we're who we are oh my god dude
you know because that that that you know
what that is that's the response that
was i didn't think about that line that
was
it's a heckler boom boom you're done
yeah
that's it and then the guilt comes in
after that
the guilty you could have said some
better [ __ ]
i did not say this
i might call my brother and say it today
just to get it out this just i want to
put that into my
[ __ ] vocabulary
[Applause]
[Music]
you